if you need help otherwise you're gonna
quit you should never get into it if
they otherwise would fill and I think
that it's pretty arrogance and now that
I don't want to be like insulting but
then I think that is kind of like bad to
say to the people why huh
they have nothing unique to give they
have nothing unique to say that's why we
disagree on already because that is not
what I did
that is also not what you get on YouTube
do it you are you didn't reinvent the
wheel and it's truly something you need
to say excuse me
the [ __ ] did you just say what do I even
title title this I don't even know what
to title it let's let's let's start it
off welcome the sort not sort of not
really a fake guru episode that I am
talking with my friend Lars and just
tell me that you reached out to me you
said you wanted to do an episode just
tell me what's the what's the idea here
no so some of your viewers might
indirectly know me or at least know my
channel which is called storytellers but
I which I do together with my best
friend Tomas so I know you but honestly
I only know you as a coffee break I
don't even know your name yeah Stephen
Stephen all right Stephen I keep the
name down oh you because we are in the
same we are on the same Facebook group
which is where a collection of video
sick I talked with each other so it's
movies in the channels and try to help
each other out a little bit and I
reached out to you because like your
second channel caught my eye on YouTube
where you are doing the fake guru views
which I thought was in a very original
concept and then there's multiple
reasons that I wanted to talk to you
about it so I've kind of like three
points that I would like to get into in
this podcast so first of all is kind of
like just the general discussion about
the fake who
see which has which like as a 25 year
old guy that is trying to start
something in his own a little bit of
entrepreneurship of course I see this
guy these guys all over my Facebook and
Instagram feed your prime target I
counted myself so I want to discuss
about that like most of your points are
agree with within there are some of the
points where like oh I thought it would
be interesting to see like where we can
like create a little bit of friction and
see like if we can if I can make a
counter argument both as a little bit of
in them that was the kind of thing
sure then the second thing and this is
also like I will actually in the works
of starting a second channel and then
also behind it
damn coaching business so when I saw
your chitta were like where your where
your when your channel came up that I
like economics idea stuff does like oh
[ __ ] like whatever I'm gonna be you know
that you know the best that's trailer
where the dog is like like who they say
me to talk with bad luck that was like
oh I want to be good coach my thing like
I also have like defend my own idea of I
own little program of what I was
planning to do and see if I can get this
for me your approval I mean not that I
would be nice to see if I can defend
myself from here let me tell you one
thing let me tell you one thing no man
is immune from the Fate guru if if you
if you commit the sins of the fake guru
you will be called out unfortunately of
course and then thirdly this is and this
is more because we bought video sa guys
and both guys there's a documentary that
I wants to discuss called Kumar a which
is very interesting documentary it has
nothing to do with like the Guru scene
of make money fast with drop shipping or
if it is marketing anything if it's more
like
the spiritual booze from India that
became very successful American and
gathered followings here right forward
Borat kind of documentary that I would
like to talk about and I try to analyze
a little bit so that's it yeah that's
kind of like the things that I wanted to
talk about on this podcast the way to
and then see see what happens
yeah yeah I like it I like the idea
alright so to start let's just talk
about fake gurus and let's just jump
into the fake guru thing you want to
become you want to become a guru but not
a fake guru right I just wanna be I mean
like I you call them gurus and then both
of them act like it but then if I say I
don't want to be called a guru those
gurus also fell and be called a guru but
basically I just want to do have a paid
service where I coach people one-on-one
with a specific goal but let's let's do
the kind of like let's do one thing
first is that almost every person you
talked about on your channel except your
little [ __ ] where you mentioned
Stephen Graham and everyone started
defending him because he seems pretty I
mean he's the kids and he's also just I
know like I watched this video and he it
just comes out as a January very nice
guy that is pretty oh I totally agree I
mean I I agree that was a video that I
like like literally through through
together and as I was talking I just saw
one of his videos the thing is a Stephen
Graham kind of does the clickbait thing
and so I just kind of lumped him and
just by association I mean I agree like
yeah so that's that's the thing like a
lot of these [ __ ] gurus day I mean
there may be multiple marketers and what
they do is very effective but then
there's a bunch of issues but then
there's like I could imagine that there
are
people that generally teach good stuff
that used the same marketing techniques
but then they also like there's also a
lot of course that use like high
pressure sales techniques and like to
fake testimonial thing and the fake
Harvard thing I mean that is so so
[ __ ] toxic and it also kind of ruins
it because generally like just in
general reviews and testimonials are
good thing like they they like a proper
business which almost reviews and honest
testimonials as a good thing so that
these guys are kind of faking and
therefore ruining testimonials because
of course it's gonna come out yeah this
is like the it creates a toxicity around
the whole coaching or mentoring industry
which is a growing industry that's also
a thing because it's so scalable like
it's so easy and everyone wants to teach
you know like everyone you know if you
go to your your to a birthday party and
you're Oscar broke divorce uncle how to
become a millionaire and have a happy
marriage you will clearly tell you
exactly how to do it even though itself
because people generally like to give
advice well the funny thing is is that
people are giving advice oh I'm so rich
and maybe they are from the coaching
business but it's only because there's
so much money to be made in the fake
guru business but the money isn't made
in the dropshipping it's not made in
affiliate mark
you can bet you're not gonna I'm the
average person it's not like I don't
know anything about drop shipping or
e-commerce like I never I never really
and also like the best of income stuff I
mean of course like with YouTube I have
some passive income but it's not it's
not huge amounts and then generally I
don't think like oh the whole like oh
yeah you will never have to work again
mindset this is bad in itself
I mean it's generally better to just
something do something you love and it's
always gonna take time to build
something and you know like
entrepreneurship in any form is most of
the time there's a steep hill to climb
and if you don't keep working you all
start
again for sure let's start let's get
into the disagreements because so far we
just agree and that's boring let's get
in the disagreement the disagreements
you like so I agree with almost all the
with the coast you discussed and then
your solution to the problem of this
coaching business and especially this
high ticket coaching business it's books
it's like it's your list Oh Frieda money
yeah it's like it's like I don't know
how many books there are um now like
like 20 or like 40 something yeah
something like yeah so but I honestly
think that most of the people that buy
these courses even already have those
books and I don't think the poops did
like with the demo some a person
democratization of information the
problem is not that the information is
out there all the informations out there
like there's nothing there's there's no
secrets anymore you can know like if I
google how to build a nuclear bomb I'll
probably can find a manual somewhere the
language is the monetizing this video
I'm gonna get enough well you're gonna
get a knock at your door and they're
gonna be like you know how to make it
yeah the point is that I don't think
that books are solution because the the
question is not so much about
information I think it's more about
about the removal of information is good
coaching is there is stuff that that
coaching does that you can't get from
books so that's what I want that's where
I like my disagreement lies and I think
that if you just say like buy this book
we is boots I think you're gonna get a
lot of information junkies a lot of
people that are like oh I want to learn
more I want to learn more I want to
learn more about business sales
marketing all this stuff and then
they're just gonna get an information
overload and then from there on they are
going to be confused or not know where
to start
and also just keep learning instead of
executing on what what the books tell
them to do and that is also like the
thing with books is that I asked for
points where I'll so the problem with
where coaching is better than books I
would argue is its leverage
accountability feedback and new ones and
so leverage is kind of the first thing
is that lets say for with fitness
coaching for example this is a very easy
example all of us know how to get ripped
and how to get in shape and not what to
eat and what to do like generally most
of us know you know don't go to
McDonald's don't drink coca-cola all day
eat veggies eat some carbs
it's of protein don't eat more than you
then you burn and go to the gym a couple
times a week but then are we all ripped
no because like we are very bad
executing on information that we already
know because knowing something and
actually doing something there's a big
difference I turn down payment so while
coaching does and with like specifically
one of our personal coaching what a
personal fitness coach would do its
first of all create a leverage so when
people come to a finish coach and they
or in this case let's put back by to
coach in general and they they pay a lot
of money like a high ticket service of
personal coaching the there is more
leverage for them to execute on what
they're being taught now of course
whatever being told has to be variable
and good knowledge and actually work but
death that is something where a book
what a coach can do other data pool
doesn't do let me let me let me jump in
here because
I have a feeling that we may be talking
past each other if I let you finish the
four points and let me tell you why I
don't disagree that coaching is
different from books but I don't think
info products are different from books
so your point is that hey look
coaching is like this one-on-one
activity where we can have very apply
very custom solutions to a problem and
don't obviously there's too much
information out there so they can kind
of fit a custom build to your prep this
just not what Dan Locke that's just not
with Sam ovens these guys are doing
they're going they're throwing you into
this 10,000 kid class they're throwing
you maybe into an a thousand person
class even 500 people at that point what
they're doing is they've recorded a
bunch of things and you can think of
them as chapters in a book if you'd like
to and they just run you through and
that's all it is you're watching a book
I mean that's essentially what you're
doing with less depth and less nuance
and that's that's what their thing is
now if you want to argue that one-on-one
coaching is a viable solution people
need but one-on-one coaching we can get
into that but let's say let's first
quantify what when I was talking about
Sam ovens and when I was talking about
like instead of this course get this I
was talking about instead of an info
product get a much cheap the original
info products for like 10 bucks and
you'll get way more value yeah no II do
totally agree with that and that is also
why almost like I have not disagreed
with any of your fake cool take downs so
far but then that's like that's the only
caveat I want positive food is that in
the indeed I also think that the intro
product info product thing is gonna like
die down I hope so because and it's also
like if you're if you're an honest
and if you're if you want to be a mentor
coach and you will help people with
something then you also like would
recognize that info products are people
aren't getting people the results that
you wanted to get you know like if you
really want to help people and you sell
them in infra product and then if you if
you go back to them and ask like how
you're doing now and you notice that
most of your people that bought your
products either haven't gotten the
results that you want them to get or
they haven't executed
executed on this because the leverage
isn't high enough and accountability
isn't high enough because of course
there's also what a coach can do is it's
like get back to a client and say like
dude I are you been doing what I tell
you to do
have you been executing or are you
running into any problems how can I help
you you know and that is where it
republic's fiddle now let's say your
coach and like every client goes like
you have a specific steps to step system
and every client goes from Step a to
step B with specific things they have to
learn then of course you can create like
pre-recorded videos for them to like
give them the basics and then from there
includes also like personalized calls
and you know like if you want to secure
your if you want skill or coaching
business then that's where you need to
find a way to if you're constantly
repeating the same things to new clients
then you have to find a way to get that
information like the basic step like
first step oh yeah and that's the whole
that's the whole guru trap then you well
have you heard about that but by the way
I I was supposed to talk about this but
um I don't I don't know if I'm gonna end
up doing a whole video about it have you
heard about the Suraj revolt thing no
he's a coder guy anyway his program he
was gonna give
one-on-one consulting calls or whatever
with people are like that that pitch was
hey join my coding group you're gonna
get one-on-one feedback I'm gonna be
directly interacting with you guys okay
so he invited five hundred there's only
give me 500 people in this group because
I totally get that you can't have more
than like you need a small class size
and that's even a huge class by the way
it turns out he he got to 505
and he got greedy and so he made a
separate slack group that no one could
see and had that had 700 people in it so
he doubled the class size without
telling anybody which completely kills
his value offer of being like I'm gonna
give you guys customs thank lying that's
the first thing that he's just scamming
I mean that's the same that's just
absolutely that's the problem with
coaching though is it's like it's a low
scalable it's not scalable because your
times not scalable and one-on-one
coaching is is like a one-to-one time
sync yeah so yeah you could you can say
like that's my coaching can be high
ticket because it's one on one and then
like scalable I mean yeah and then lever
and then of course nuance and feedback I
mean I think we're yeah
do not pass each other I think we can
agree on that is that with coaching with
helping each other you can get into the
nuances of stuff and if like the book
get into a very specific problem they
can get back to me and then you can
nuance like you can get into the small
details of stuff and of course the
feedback is it's an extension of that
let me let me give you let me give you a
quick thing because I want to extend my
argument here so no one confuses me
because I feel like a lot of people sort
of misunderstood what I was saying
because a lot of people have brought it
up okay so first of all yeah coaching is
not cut 101 coaching is not what I'm
criticizing it's it's the info info
products the overpriced info product
which are already high ticket items but
then to extend my coaching how I feel
about coaching is that because coaching
has to be a high ticket item because it
doesn't scale I feel like those kind of
high ticket items really the value comes
when you're talking an expert is getting
coaching to take them to the next level
to where they cannot basically bring
themselves to the next level by
themselves and I feel like what instead
a lot of people do to get their coaching
business started is they
cast their net as widely as possible and
they tell beginners hey you need coach
hey you know and the reality is you
don't as a beginner there's so much that
you can learn on your own and you should
learn on your own cuz it's a waste of
money to have a coach sit over your
shoulder and tell you these super
obvious things what this and this is why
I think consulting at the highest level
makes a lot of sense if you're if you're
some CEO and you want Tony Robbins to
consult you to like take you from like
super like high performing to super high
performing I get it I really do get it
but if you're coaching like an eighteen
year old and because you have to coach
one-on-one you have to charge them a ton
of money which they do almost by
definition don't have that's what I
think you get into the predatory side of
what high ticket items for young people
can be which is people think it's a way
out and in reality it's not at all I
mean it's a little bit definitely
predatory with the predatory aspect of
looking at like SS like for very young
people especially people that are in a
place where they are really stuck enough
money yet and they can barely afford it
then to say like then to target them and
say like oh this is your way out but you
have to pay me so much money and it even
like especially the thing where they buy
a product and then they don't succeed
with that product and then you're like
oh no yeah well then find another phone
I'm so [ __ ] [ __ ] off like it would
be like it would be so much better if it
was like like oh I teach you to get like
5k a month or something and then only
when you have reached that goal then I
can help you to get even more like they
want the money they need the money they
want the money dude that is
like this other stuff and [ __ ] up i
don't i don't agree with like like
beginner there's the beginner steps
because like I said like I think like so
many people like once you get the ball
rolling it and you're going into a very
a very good direction then things start
happening automatically at least like
okay we'll get into this later but like
Matt what I want to do especially with
that but then with a lot of beginners is
like in the beginning point depth you
get like stuck in a Matar you going into
a wrong direction or you get you've got
like yeah that's it that's exactly where
you like and that you give off because
you you're trying you're gues getting
stuck in a moth you don't have results
and then you give up well you know like
at the highest level then okay but then
it's also like with them okay so and I
also don't think like you have to be an
absolute expert with it like 100 years
of experience and something to come to
coach I think that if you're like 5 to
10 steps ahead of something and you also
promised them to not coach them beyond
your own where you are you know like if
you like authenticity and honesty is
think as a coaches and so if you want to
be coach is very important so let's say
you're making dynamic some success in
something and you're like okay I want to
get my clients to like twenty percent of
where I am like that because of course
it took me to like let's say you're
taking you are something and took you
two years now you wanna do coaching
program help clients and then you're
saying like oh I want to get into 20
percent over am so so let's let's get
into what I want to do so there's a lot
of reasons that I wanted to do that I
got that idea and I was like way before
I even discovered your second channel
like coffee still of course I already
knew about coffee break but like
I'm also totally honest about it I love
storytellers I love what we do with film
analysis thing on our Channel
but there are some inherent weak points
of storytellers of that channel that I'm
discussing also with Thomas and that is
that we have a massive audience but our
videos just generally take so much time
to make and always keep doing it and I
love to do it but I stand also the
volatility of our results of so you know
like some videos get 20,000 views and
some videos get 500,000 views and then
you work it sponsors for example because
that and we deal with copyright so our
Adsense is weak because of copyrights
like that's because we want to make I
want to make youtube or storytellers
into my career like that is my cool and
I think that is perfectly almost cool to
have so with storytellers it's we're
getting into a area where we have a weak
sense because copyright and we don't
have a physical product finals now for
some people patron works excellent for
us
Reed doesn't and we put like 50 to 80
hours into a video essay so then from
there I started thinking like okay what
if I could do a new channel next to my
original channel and what are the
problems that could solve so I could and
I I could start making more original
content which is also my own inspiration
and my own aspiration to learn more
about camera filmmaking but right now
we're only editing and then that's will
resolve the copyright issue and then can
I also have a service or something
behind it and that's where the coaching
comes in and that was kind of and it's
know what the coaching mean yeah I would
the coaching be what would you become
yeah like my channel would be an
extension of my most successful video
which is kind of like how an artist
turns Pro and that's kind of like
getting through trade blocks and mental
blocks but then the coaching like the
actual thing that I really want to do is
help people build our own YouTube
like similarly to youtubers like roberto
blake i think media creators like those
kinds of channels that are dedicated to
helping people build their own youtube
channel and so the goal because of
course like i don't our channel right
now is at 250,000 subscribers so i'm not
gonna say like oh i'm gonna teach you
how to build a 1 million subscriber
YouTube channel in 12 weeks
like my proposition that I want to like
get into is how people get those first
thousand in and that's why that's
because where I disagree with you with
about the beginning like like you say
like oh in the beginning you can just do
so much yourself you don't need coaching
yet like I've been doing target audience
research and looking at what people are
struggling with because I won't first
know what people are strongly with
before I can help them with it right so
people that are completely stuck at like
the first hundred subscribers and don't
get through it and then I look at it and
then I see well why do you think hold on
oh no no no why do you think that is
because I'm very opinionated on starting
YouTube and like how it should go
so tell me why do you think people are
stressed stuck at 100 subscribers huh
why do you think people are stuck at 100
subscribers oh well I mean it's sure
like your fairy opinion so now I'm
curious but your oh I mean I don't think
the content is good enough like like
okay here's here's the thing here's the
thing I did I made a I had a channel
before coffee break where I basically
did it for three years
I made a hunt I got a hundred videos out
before I had a hundred subscribers and
looking back the content was just bad
and I needed that time just grinding and
to realize that oh I'm just making bad
content and it's hard to even have an
eye for what it's like developing tastes
than anything it just takes time to
understand what how how what makes a
video good what makes a video entertain
what kind of topics are entertaining
this is not something that like somebody
can just tell you and I know it because
I've I've tried to talk to beginner
youtubers like just like kind of like
they ask me something and I'll try to
tell them and I try to get things into
their head and it's like it goes right
over their head and the reason for that
is not because they're dumb it's not
because I'm smart
it's because there's an experienced side
that cannot be hacked it's like you just
have to put in your time sort of at the
gym just like just like if you're
developing a hold on did I lose you
on the call I think okay no no can you
hear me yeah okay sorry sorry sorry it
was just a little fishy yeah yeah as
long as you can hear what I'm saying
just like when you're drawing when
you're drawing like you just need to put
in a certain amount of time learning to
draw and learning to draw well and
there's no point in focusing on how much
you can sell your artwork for before you
just learn how to make good art and so
for me I think there's an obsession with
numbers at the beginning when the
obsession should be with content because
the truth is I've never found someone
with a hundred subscribers who was
making super good content that six
months later didn't have the subscribers
that I thought that it was much more in
the ballpark of what they should have
like maybe they're making mediocre
content and they stay at 100 subscribers
but nobody has ever made like awe
inspiring content and then they're just
like 100 subscribers for 6 months like
it just doesn't happen so that's my
obtain that's my opinion so I just think
like get good I mean I mean everyone has
to do it it's not no one's above the the
grind
I beat partially I you see a lot of
channels that are completely so Lexie
like I'm looking like people before
struggling with and then I am in some
Facebook groups and like most of them
are horrible because it's just people
link dropping and asking for soft
surprise for subscribers which of course
is the fastest way to destroy your own
channel immediately and I it's baffling
to me that people still do it like I
don't know
why are these people are or what they're
thinking but although I do I do get a
guy like that I of the guy that I can
elegent and then he just got probed into
the idea that Oh like okay YouTube only
starts promoting like your dog Enomoto
starts helping you once you have reaches
thresholds for this I buy your till you
get told and then and then you'll grow
naturally which of course also doesn't
work smart for that
I do i I was not so I have yeah sorry I
was just gonna say like the algorithm
things really interesting because I
complain a lot about the algorithm and I
feel like and I feel like it's something
that can be a crutch and you can blame
too much on it when sometimes it's just
bad content and then but there is like a
root there is a reality to I mean that's
like a really hard catch-22 but I think
when you're a beginner thinking about
the algorithm is absolutely worthless
because no matter what it has nothing to
do with the algorithm like if you just
have bad I told I told my because so I
actually already have two clients and we
can get into that later with one of my
clients was like Oh sounds like how do I
need to either is actually a pretty
successful ready like he's doing is
fitness coach himself and he's doing
already like like five to eight pay a
month and getting new clients mostly to
an Instagram which is doing very well
but any wants to get into YouTube as
well as like a second traffic source and
he already was started and like he did
like even like a whole bunch of things
bad and then he reached out to me and he
was like we found each other more like
and hey he asked me for my help
and then he was like also like how can I
do
like how would your suggestion be on
video titling and tags and descriptions
and I was like dude you can you can you
can literally have the exact key phrase
in your title in description or tags
everywhere I can do everything correctly
and your video is still gonna be even
nowhere near the search result is just
not gonna happen you know especially in
the beginning YouTube is not gonna
promote your videos a lot and so but
what I do know very well is how too many
we promote that's also I proved in an
organic way of course in which real
subscribe your views and that is how I
like ah how we grew SOI terrorists like
in the beginning when awesome YouTube
algorithm wasn't doing anything for us
naturally so I have some confidence in
that so but then like now at first I'm
just helping him create content you know
like I'm helping like like he comes
smooth questions about camera settings
also like like soft jxne and like it's
just like working together in a material
way where it's like step step for step
and I'd like I know that I know what I'm
doing and I know I can get them there
and he tried himself to get there and he
was just not so if I can break through
like him fumbling around and going in
circles and help him like go in the
right direction that is valuable and of
course like that is also the clients
that I want to work with is people that
have that already have some stuff going
for themselves and that are not just
like looking for YouTube like to make
money fast or like like way out or
something you know like I want to find
people that have buying power because if
I'm gonna work with them over twelve
weeks three months of helping them build
a channel and I'm gonna like weekly
calls with them and I'm sending up
documents for them and I'm doing like
recording like screen recording stuff
like I'm putting in a lot of effort a
lot of time for my clients so I need I'm
trying to find people that have buying
power and also people that have kind of
like don't have the weak spots that I
had with storage those if their goal is
to make money with YouTube then I'm like
okay the best thing is to have a service
product behind your channel ready but
then you know of course I'm gonna
encounter a lot of people like fitness
coaches from NFA and it's also gonna go
again into the servers and coaching
stuff but it would be very interesting
to me to work actually with someone that
has a physical product for example like
like some of the paints or something
that someone that or my girlfriend for
example is a jewelry designer like if
she wants to do YouTube so that you can
find an audience for jewelry and baby
makes himself sales through it that
would be very interesting to me to work
with those kinds of people so but right
now like I'm very much in the beginning
of setting this up and this idea that's
why I also still of anxiety about it and
a lot of you know like one thing is
getting new clients and then other
things like can I can I deliver them
results because I know myself and then
at this point if I had to start over of
course I can build another channel off
to like at least a couple thousand
subscribers relatively fast because I
know how to make good poly content and I
not promote myself organically but can I
help others because YouTube is something
that can be very based on personality
also as well that's why also like I
don't want to work I decided that I
would like to work with people that are
like an educational space and the
offering value space and not so much
personality based youtubers that work
that I like gaming youtubers because
that niche is also almost impossibly
saturated Beauty vloggers and more
person floggers it's as a whole there's
not people that I want to work with
because I feel I can't guarantee to get
them results because it's so personality
based which and when you how much do you
want to charge for this
Oh how much do you want - how much you
want to charge for this so might like
that structure that I'm gonna work
without that I work with myself is 12
weeks of coaching so three months and
it's basically 12 weeks of once or twice
a week a coaching call like for
definition wants and if they run into
like some really serious like that I
can't that I can't figure out for them
just over text then I can do another
coaching call beside that they can text
me if they run me through something or
they're okay we I need a number Lars I
need a number I have to look I have one
guy that's a guy I already had a channel
I helped it for free but I just did one
call and I'm believed like this channels
already growing from like he was growing
from other subscribe to mouth and now he
said around four times a month so that's
a good thing then I've got the fitness
guy like fitness coach that wants to
build a YouTube channel
I charged him 500 for 3 months as a
client so like well like 67 for 3 months
in a row he's still setting up his
channel and he's gonna produce his first
video is that is that gonna be is that
gonna be your long-term no I'm asking
what is your gonna be your price when
you officially launched this thing when
you're no longer like thinking about it
give me a price if I wanted large three
months consulting I'm a new guy start if
I'm if I'm hearing this right now if I'm
coffee Zillah three months from now
finding out about large consulting
business what am I gonna hear you're
charging for 3 months it's so 3 times 3
so 333 dollars a month divided by 4
basically 4.5 calls a month so you're
basically charging $75 for how long's
the call 90 minutes like what hour and a
half until the client knows what they
want to know and then off to and of
course also like I mean that's honestly
not a crazy that's honestly not an
insane consulting because I'm looking at
my competition there's a channel called
pink media and it also helps people
build their video like video mostly in
YouTube build the channels and they
focus mostly on businesses that's when I
use YouTube for a marketing each arson
charges 2004 two calls so a thousand a
call yeah that that's the kind of stuff
that I think's predatory you're
basically charging but then it really
does put honest it does put on this 50
bucks an hour it does it does put on
this what do you call it on this website
he does put there that like this is
mostly for businesses like for big
companies that want to integrate YouTube
because that's also something like this
buying power and value like the
predatory stuff when you focus on people
that don't have a lot of money and then
you're like I'm gonna save your life and
I'm gonna ask you two thousand three
thousand five thousand dollars for
something and you don't have money but
just scrape together sell everything
because I'm gonna change your life
honestly but those are the people most
likely to go and want a someone to help
them out of their situation like the
people who are most likely to go for a
consulting call from a youtuber are not
people this is just my intuition I don't
know maybe maybe could prove me wrong
are not people who already kind of have
it together and who are probably should
be the ones that are qualified for you
the people who are going to be the most
profitable market for you are actually
going to be the people who know nothing
you disagree how many people do you
think are like qualified but also cannot
find their way to above a thousand
subscribers or like can't figure it out
I mean like I said like one of my
clients is
it's a fitness dude he's doing [ __ ]
amazing on Instagram and that's why I
like was a little bit confused when I
talked to him because he was like oh I
don't know for sure what kind of
software should talk about in YouTube or
and he made like a couple videos already
and then he posted a couple 40 minutes
post cost videos and that's I already
like okay dude if you're just starting
out nobody's gonna listen to you for 50
minutes because they nobody knows you
yet you know like once you have a huge
audience then people and people know you
who then they're gonna listen to you
more but he's already like he's making
plenty of money plenty of money feeling
is coaching for like fitness guys like
he's helping people lose weight build
muscle and he's been making plenty of
income for Beth
and I actually kind of because also the
things like if I can help him build this
channel and a thousand subscribers thing
is also especially because with YouTube
in the beginning of YouTube the first
thousand anything harder status but I
don't know for you but for us we're
storytellers like for the first couple
months nothing happens and then we
started building then we started
promoting it organically and then it
started growing and then once we reach
the thousands it's kind of then it
became a little bit more automatic and
algorithm was a little bit more start
picking us up and we didn't have to push
that hard anymore to gain stone growth
yeah I like if I can help him like break
through that first like problem and even
if I again can get him a couple only if
it's like because he already has the
coaching business I mean if I gave him
one or two new clients through YouTube
and he already tied himself and he
didn't he filled he didn't you couldn't
build a channel and I can help him do
that to the first out in and then from
there he starts growing automatically
and he gets new clients to date so then
he already has a return on investment
but here's my question here's my
question number one I just think the a
thousand barrier is just like a function
of I mean it's like a it's a time thing
I don't know how you can hack your way
sort of that will tell me like what
could you tell somebody who already kind
of knows how to make content who already
kind of has figured that out what can
you tell them that would be like truly
worth
a thousand dollars over three men like
how could you like what are you saying
that I couldn't tell you of anything
also because if I tell you exactly how
to promote your channel then people are
going to be abusive that make bad
content that is why my way I'm I want to
teach people it's like twelve weeks like
first I want to focus the way you
telling me you have a secret so great
that anyone can abuse it and get a
thousand subscribers that's what you're
telling me right now pretty much no they
can't there are people to figure out do
not I mean maybe maybe like you do it
once you have a thousand subscribers but
it is the most effective way okay yeah
what is that
tell me tell me what it is tell me what
it is it's not the the thing that I'm
most the most proud of like the most
with my other clients he's actually he's
trying to start a channel in like the
watch yes yes he has a love for watch
watch wristwatches collecting risk sure
and that's actually kind of like that is
actually pretty big niche on YouTube
and what he wants to do is make more
kind of like a video essay channel
around around wristwatches but then make
it a few sa so more like philosophical
video essays about like cross and
wristwatches is where this spell and
like the luckiest I have certain ideas
about it like he wanted to make his
first video you wanted to combine like
the widespread format of you know they
have like deep word um yeah and you
wanted to do like that you want to do a
video about collecting wristwatches
likewise or waste of money like
something like that and that does their
demos what he wants what he's trying to
do so and any like it was like the it
really wasn't do but he was like really
afraid that it was gonna fill and he was
kind of like getting stuck and he was
kind of like always giving up already
and then I was like dude don't give up
like you're not even started yet like
trusting yourself that you can do this
what he was doing like he was writing a
script for his first video and he got
into this he got into this problem where
he was trying to and I think a lot of
crying video essays when they want to
write something about a movie or want to
do is say they want a reinvents and they
want to come with this totally original
new take on the film or or something
that they want to make a video essay
about which if you have experience while
writing essays universe me you know that
it's not how you write an essay your
essay most of the time a good essay it's
not a reinvention of the wheel with a
completely original out of the blue
nobody has thought of this argument what
you do is and this what I told them is
what you do is you take arguments of
other people and you take your own
arguments and then you create those
together into one coherent essay where
you're kind of placing you replace
yourself in a debate that's how you
write an essay and the any of us like it
clicked for him and then he actually
wrote it and now we're in a feedback
stage so then and then he was like oh
dude like you explain my own kind of
mental block that to me that I could
himself and it comment through so yeah
so like I'm proud of that like I'm proud
of helping him like being able to get
him through that where otherwise you
probably would have already given up on
this channel idea so dude okay yeah this
is where I get cynical because uh I feel
like if you're gonna give up on your
okay this is I guess I can break it out
like this yeah if if if you need help
otherwise you're gonna quit you should
never get into it like I think if you're
gonna quit unless you get help I mean
I'm kind of like do it
DIY is the way and it's sort of the only
way I don't think it's like you know
what it's a lot like it's a it's a lot
like
this reminds me a lot of because YouTube
in a lot of ways is a creative endeavor
and so it's like saying like hey I'm
gonna take a comedy class to learn how
to be smart to learn or to learn how to
be funny
to learn how to not bomb at an open mic
and I think the very premise of that is
a fundamentally misguided way to
approach comedy he's like I'm gonna
learn from somebody else how you know
and even like a lot of these comics talk
about it because obviously it's a
lucrative career move to everyone
there's a lot of people who want to be
comics and so to teach a class is like
kind of this very compelling idea but
then a lot of other comics are like well
there's no way there's no way to teach
this like this is just something that
you just get good at by failing a lot
and and my thought is like isn't that a
lot of what YouTube is is like you're
just kind of fail a lot until you start
to succeed and you get better and this
and this and I don't think I by the way
I I don't think if you advertise
ethically
and if you don't like mainly my fake
guru thing is a lot about advertising
just because that's that's everything if
you did if no one promised these
ridiculous results I wouldn't call them
fake gurus so I think if you advertise
ethically I don't think there's
something wrong per se but since you're
still thinking about it I would just
tell you like you've got to think like
is is this is this an idea where it you
have to believe in it you have to
fundamentally believe in it you believe
you believe in the value proposition of
like coaching people who are just
getting started on YouTube you believe
in the value proposition of like
coaching someone who's getting on
started on YouTube and you see that as
worth a thousand dollars like I said if
I can
[Music]
if yeah I mean if they otherwise would
fill and I think that it's pretty
arrogant that and now I don't want to be
like insulting but then this is the
thing like for you and me right now this
is something that we do have figured out
and we know it sort of for you like oh
let's kind of feel ourselves think
you're just gonna just gonna
they just gotta like they gotta keep
trying until they figure it out and then
they will solve it and then it will also
succeed and then I think that it's kind
of like bad to say for to the people why
huh but that's exactly I mean I'm I'm
just speaking from experience what I'm
just speaking from experience I'm not
saying hey do something that I didn't do
myself I mean this is something that I
have intimate experience with and I
actually credit my failures in the past
for and not giving up at those points
for the future success and it's not like
I'm like wildly successful but I still
think I'm in the process of failure into
getting better failure into getting
better and like to me if at step one
which is where you should recognize the
foot most failures gonna happen you
immediately kind of are like trying to
lifeline I just think how are you gonna
deal with it's like you've got if you
you can say like okay there's gonna be a
lot of failure in the beginning anyway
you kind of have to get through that I
figured out that way
but the whole thing about coaching is
not taking away all failure but it's
trying to minimize that to help people
minimize it and getting through specific
steps quicker like getting through like
preventing mistakes that you made and
helping people not make the same
mistakes in the beginning of the process
and if you can cut a learning curve like
that which I think you can in a myriad
of area
including sports you know like I could I
when I learned to play tennis when I was
young I could have just in leads just
spent years hitting a ball and figuring
it out and maybe end up with horrible
technique or I could get a tennis coach
that would help me minimize the learning
curve and teach me proper technique I
think we're talking about something that
is like I guess I see things more from
the creative side and I think that you
should learn like like no but I don't
think anyone should be telling you how
to make your videos I don't think people
should be telling you you know what
style of content to make I don't think
people should be like basically
babysitting you through the basics
because there's so much failure I'm
trying to think of like a good way to to
say this because the difference between
tennis and like and YouTube is most
people are getting into YouTube as sort
of like a business opportunity and most
people are not getting into tennis is
like I'm gonna go pro and I think
fundamentally the value proposition of a
tennis coach is like I'm gonna help you
learn this like lifelong skill whereas
the fundamental proposition of like a
youtube coach is basically implicit is
like I'm gonna help you somehow get
profitable or get somewhere on YouTube
to basically leverage it because that's
actually something that my original
thought would be there because like
specifically because of that you know
like tennis is not tennis is a skill and
it's it's a passion most people are not
getting into it to become a professional
tennis player like all that unless
they're very young and they start
playing and they get scouted or
something and then they might try to
take it more seriously or they just want
to make like heavens
mosey that's putting a knobby and
something their profession for so I'm
with men my idea I was like I was
thinking like okay like okay if I'm
gonna ask money for this like will
people will people like that I have to
find a way where I can help people the
way that they kind of return can get a
return investment in of their
investments so specifically like I said
like if I can get a youtuber new clients
for an already existing creative
endeavor that they are trying to build a
business out or like I said like the
fitness guy rule made might get new
leads through YouTube but then I
actually noticed when I started
interviewing people that also a lot of
people actually were like I was like so
what are your like what are you have
goals for you to blackball do you what
do you want to get out of it and then
people were like well it's nice if it
would make some money but it would be
just really cool so we have a community
and an audience for the stuff that I
want to talk about and then I was like
okay so like if I can help you build
that audience which be willing which be
willing to to pay for that if you
otherwise don't know figuring out if you
olofi everything like also people just
like get held back the empties I mean I
don't know maybe you can't relate it
maybe you're very much into the like you
gotta hustle you gotta try it out and if
you've quit if you quit if you quit
immediately then you were never done a
baby
no yeah get it get out of here anyway
the hell out of here you're not doing it
on your own out of my anxiety to get
fear even I have that like still
sometimes like I sit down to edit and
I'm like [ __ ] I hope this is gonna come
out the way I wanted to come out you
know like so if like that is because
this becomes valuable like otherwise
like some people just like need a little
push and as a coach you can you can
provide it and then they you we can
argue about an intrinsic value of that
but then
if they've if they otherwise if there's
something that really won't but they're
just scared or they just anxiety about
it and you can help them get through
that and they think that is worthy of
paying for then I don't see where the
loss is why it's not a win-win like why
is someone losing that especially and
this is like so for example this is why
I wouldn't say this to someone that has
no money at all and it's struggling and
his death and it's like I would like you
know that then then don't pay for it but
if it's a guy like for my client that
wants to do the watch channel East has
an excellent job in a credit card like I
think for most car and he wants to and
he wants to build this channel mostly
because he has a passion for watches and
he has a lot for video essays and also
film you studied film in university
never did anything with it he was just
like I won't start YouTube but I don't
know how but I really want the creative
outlet if you can help me help me yeah
no yeah you were like get out but then
I'm like no okay I like he's like I like
I said early like I said earlier I I
think if you do this business in the
right way you don't oversell what you're
gonna get for people I don't think
there's anything wrong with it it this
is just happens to have intersected with
something that I core believe about
YouTube and this actually gets into
something else that I wanna that I sort
of could discuss with you a little bit
is like where it's interesting because
tennis is like I was interested about
your tennis proposition and there was
like something fundamentally back there
that I didn't agree with the analogy and
I didn't know why but I figured it out
tennis is sort of it's a game with set
rules and there's a set way to win and
because there's a set way to win they're
sort of like the way to coach tennis I
mean even though there's probably styles
of coaching it's like everyone kind of
agrees on like fundamental strategies
and like there's a there's a very direct
way you can approach coaching tennis
I feel like coaching YouTube
specifically coaching how to get an
audience is not like deterministic in
the way that tennis is if you can just
get someone a good forehand like there's
a set way to get someone to good form on
a forehand there's a set way to get
someone a good back end there's a set
way to get people to serve the right way
I I think with YouTube because so much
of it is personality based and niche
content based like that is I I don't
think there's a good way to teach that
and that's maybe why I'd like really
kind of reject the idea of or I don't
believe in like coaching youtubers and
I've always kind of believed this that
there's no one who can tell you how to
be original you know what I mean like
the real way to get popular on YouTube
and to like cultivate an audience is to
have something unique to say like have
something original to say that's why we
disagree already because that is not
what I did that is not that is also not
what you get on YouTube dude you're
you're intended reinvent the wheel and
that truly something you need to say no
no no no and what you did is you placed
you did a lot of things like you started
coffee break first thing you did is you
place yourself very specifically in the
video at say niche you niche down
properly you didn't make a channel of
like I'm gonna be a vlogger and I'm
gonna talk it I got into gaming and I'm
also gonna do a video essays and I'm
gonna do this and this is this and I see
a lot of people out there would do this
I would and then like it's not maybe
it's not a specific like I never I would
not claim to say like oh you can do
different kind of contents and not
succeed because of course there are
people that do succeed but what I would
say is that if I would teach YouTube
which I am gonna try I would say is
niche down fine oh man we think they now
are getting to the core disagreement
because number one number one I would
say you did original work which is the
whole reason I found you in the whole
reason I liked you and then I would say
yes a hundred percent I did original
work and let me define original real
quick so no one thinks I'm like
to claim something I'm not I don't mean
original as in I pushed forward I it
like any individual idea which was
completely detached from all other ideas
that have ever been thought of I mean in
the synthesis idea of what you mean but
they're within synthesis like there's
this idea of remix in everything which
there's this guy who yeah yeah yeah
that's that's the video I like but it
but that fundamentally comes from
everything is a remix whoo there's a guy
a famous guy you know I can't remember
his name
anyway anyway he basically argues that
yeah everyone is basically some form of
copying but the thing that I sort of
disagree there is that there's a
difference between copying and
synthesizing there's a difference
between trying to be exactly like Casey
nice that and use the Gorillapod and the
exact same camera and having the boosted
board lifestyle you see so many of those
guys out there and I'm not saying none
of those have people have their own take
but a lot of them have like a very
similar they're just trying to do what
Casey nice that did and fundamentally
they will never be as popular as Casey
nice that because he's already done it
they have nothing unique to give they
have nothing unique to say and I mean
unique in the sense of when you
synthesize you're making something
unique and so like I did a video about
bad words and I did it about comedians
and basically I synthesized a Benjamin
Bergen idea which is like a linguist
professor which by the way I defy you to
find a bunch of video essays who are
talking about bad words and how it
contextualizes through comedy I think
there's like ways to do unique things
like that's why I fundamentally disagree
and I think you should try not to do
some things that other people are doing
but like like the core I the core ideas
were not themselves unique but by
blending together the way you talk about
them you can create something unique and
you can have unique perspectives on it
and I think that is what you cannot
oh yeah but this is exactly what I think
you can teach because and that's this
this is not a core of this agreement
because I agree exactly with it that
synthesis is synthesizing sound
something is totally different from
copying it the do it when you when you
go to universe is the whole thing you
did that the comments are definitely
gonna be like oh it's not about you
diversity but no one's gonna watch this
far into the interview anyway so don't
worry if you go but if you go to the
University if you go to university
what do they do they teach you how to
think and they teach you how to write an
essay they teach you how to synthesize
information from different sources and
come up with an original concept an
original argument or at least an
argument that adds onto an existing
debates in a scholarly debate that is
what you do and that is I think also why
storytellers are successful because like
you just like the struggle that you had
we didn't really have that minterms from
bones in university doing media and
cultural sciences which was basically
film television and new media and then
from we were already doing learning how
to do film analysis and then I found I
was like on YouTube and we I found the
nerdfighter and I found every frame
painting
and at that point I was like oh like I'm
writing about film I want to learn more
the technical aspect of editing I can I
think I can make a video essay like this
I think I could do something like this
so I used the skill set of film analysis
that I learned in university learned
anything with Premiere Pro and made my
first video essay and so for us the
quality was kind of like from the very
beginning the colony was already there
like I mean this nights how it's
arrogant with them to prove through
two-sided points is that my first ever
video essay is still like an artist I
think it's like anything wise it's a bad
it's about si and also like I used that
microphone I still struggle with with my
voice which is one of my weak points but
then content wise it is still my most
successful videos to this day but yeah I
learned like the skill sets that I had
to make that video I learned them from
professors so the same thing like I said
now like the guy that wants to do a
video SH and all surrounding more of
like style and the history of
watchmaking and where i'm watched making
a he is video si the script is focusing
for example about where can you put
things like arts in the hierarchy of
needs and like like he's trying to make
play and that is what I told him like
that is what I help them with it's like
dude don't reinvent the wheel don't try
to come up with this unique argument
about watches find current like finds
different arguments place yourself in
the debate come up with your own like
there make your own arguments and try to
have like that's how you do it
and that's I help like he said I help
them with that so I think I told him
something and with the like the whole
value how valuable is that I don't know
like that that's up to the coach and the
client also as well sure but I like to
say like you can't you can't I'd would
say you can't be like this and this is
also something that I'm still like
figuring out myself like if I want to
teach people how to make youtube [ __ ]
and help me my girlfriend this if you
want to coach people to make something
creative it's also gonna be my
responsibility to to like to bollixed
and do I say this it's better if you do
this and to what extent do I left them
their own creativity like take the wheel
like like we're a platform what point
should I say like Oh figure out yourself
and try to have your own creativity and
your own
expertise come in at this point so yeah
that is a balance I agree with that like
you can't you can't also not people you
can't tell people exactly do it like
this and this and this and this and take
away all their own input because that
would be a better that idea as well
right right well I know I'll say to like
I mean you may have like learned a few
ideas and in like the maybe the skills
of film analysis at university but it's
your unique blend of filmmaking your
background your perspective you know all
these things that ends up giving your
channel the voice and a uniqueness that
it does have I mean
you I think you know like when I'll
watch video I say sometimes and one of
my biggest bones to pick is not that
people choose to do film analysis but it
seems like everyone chooses to do film
analysis and I'm like why are we
sticking this genre into like 90% film
Anna I don't understand it like it's
like you could do so much more
yeah that with the format the format of
video essays is like is it stuck in and
I kind of blame it to some extent on on
nerdwriter and every frame of painting
who like have just every third writer by
the way has sort of gotten away from
that which I'm happy I'm very happy
about a little bit he still deals with
it but like he does video essays that
are sort of in the miscellaneous but I
just feel like the the format could be
so much bigger than but it but because
so many people want to like replicate
what has been done and like they're just
like oh well I'll just copy what's been
successful and I'm like no like I I feel
like a good approach to YouTube might be
if there's anything to teach is look
around at what everyone's doing and then
do not do that do not do what everyone
else is doing at least have something
unique whether it's in the format
whether it's in the topic whether it's
in how you approach the topic like
please don't just copycat somebody
else's style
I mean I I just don't think that's a way
to be successful and because of that how
much can you teach the absence of
copying copy yeah I mean I disagree I
disagree I disagree completely I think I
think we touch base we're just like I
think like if ever here and this is the
middle and we're both like just on the
other side like because we're not on
both sides like close bulb then
different sides of the wall because then
I think I think I don't think I think
it's dangerous when you tell people to
be like find something truly original
because then they're gonna [ __ ]
themselves into like mine talked them
into thinking that whatever they come up
with has already been done like because
most stuff is already set
that's just like most stuff if you dig
deeper and that is also where I don't
agree with you like everyone was doing
feel nervous because there's plenty of
video essay guys that are doing yeah
maybe I don't don't you think so there's
there's like plenty of nobody I think
but I mean I actually have been trying
to like I've been talked it sounds like
all can we move out of it it's just like
because we also have interested interest
in history and all their like
philosophical subjects and then but then
we're still freaking out like format
wise or like are we gonna do animation
or are we gonna like hire someone to do
the animation so we're still figuring it
out but then they're already plenty of
guys I didn't think the nerdfighter
always did multiple stuff like even when
he started this channel yeah it was kind
of like a vlogging thing to promote his
own book I think he wrote a book and he
was trying to do YouTube to get an
audience to sales book too before he
moved then like he was already talking
about personally it's like oh all the
nerve and how it's been
but then the thing is now film is this
is the most like no I mean it's very
successful well I gave with a
nerdfighter like when he goes into
popular media his videos tense and to do
very very well okay where I disagree
it's like because that was my videos
like still like an artist don't try to
find something truly unique but stand on
the shoulders of giants and then try to
add like 20% of your own magic or 10% of
your own magic but it's perfectly of
fine to draw like not like inspiration I
think you can draw or not only be
inspired by other people which can you
can draw from other people and I also
think that your own your own like like
well if I say like become 20 percent
unique I think that is not only I think
that's actually in a viable because even
women are like but if I do it when I
started I was like if I can talk as
smoothly as the writer with this voice
thank you for August smoothie as he does
if I can edit smoothie easy dose that
would be amazing but of course like our
style became a little different because
I found different effects that I liked
the years I found different like things
I like sound effects that I want to use
maybe different way of like music we
like to use and then we moved it from
him almost automatically yeah the things
that were like when I'm actually in my
next video
which I'm trying to upload this week is
also again a change of formats and it's
more it's still movies and I would say
it's still video essay because it still
has an argument but there's no voiceover
grants more like video essay and also
like very another
Stewart 23m like these guy that makes
super cuts of movies and those kind of
stuff that's I mean I think they're very
underappreciated and masterful editors
that make like I think it's our it's not
a video I say I'll send you something
later but I think it's really amazing
job or something like that
but I'm still have like an argument that
video sc/st argument in it but of course
like I draw same thing like that format
of more poetic video essay that it's
more editing based I drew from them and
I drew from my own experience and the
own argument that I want to make but
it's always it's always a mix
everything's remixed like you like you
said you know like yeah that's that's
that's what I oh that's where I I would
when you tell people like dude you gotta
have this unique original concept
otherwise it's all Rises dude then I
think you're gonna discourage people
that otherwise would no no no I feel
like you're gonna encourage them to look
I just feel like the amount of things
that aren't talked about it's it's
because everyone just goes to people I
want to find out something how do I do a
video I say oh well everyone's doing
filming out so I guess I'll do film
analysis and you know who's the guy to
talk about well it's David Fincher so
I'll just do a David Fincher video
there's just so many things that have
not been talked about and so many things
that are like waiting for someone to
cover them but just because they're not
popular in the zeitgeist
no one is like copying what has not been
done and so what I'm saying is like you
don't even have to have a super original
thing but as long as you talk about
something that hasn't been talked about
for a while you could have a much more
compelling I'm just tired I'm just tired
of seeing the same recycled like formats
or like opinions that are not it's not
because it's not because they're like
not entirely original it's just because
I've heard them repeated and repeated
and repeated and I can tell the people
are reading the same sources they're not
trying to like go beyond you know of
the first page of Google to like find
out what they think about the subject
and that's just my like core core the
org or god forbid they read one book and
summarize the one book and it's like
okay well we've got we can do better
than this that's all I'm saying is like
it's like we can do better and there's
so many topics that haven't been covered
that I would just like to see that
anyway whatever we're getting to we're
getting too deep I've got six minutes
before I actually have to go so have we
to not talked about anything let's talk
about the law right real quick really
quick really quick welcome all right did
you see the trailer I've seen his TED
talk on it
the Kumari for everyone who doesn't know
is this Indian guy who just says what if
I become a fake guru literally does the
whole premise of the documentary and he
gets like real followers people who
really believe in him and then at the
end he says like I'm not a guru whatever
or like yeah like I'm not who you think
I am or something but the followers were
like really getting something out of his
faking the thing which I think is the
whole point of the documentary yeah well
that was kind of like the discussion I
mean we have to watch it and I did a
like an elective course on documentary
filmmaking and it was kind of like the
morality of documentary filmmaking parts
that we have to watch this documentary
because at the beginning is it's very
much like a Borah kind of documentary
always like tricking people and becoming
you know like he's very Americanized and
then he sees all these Western people
following Indian gurus and then he's
like I'm gonna become an Indian guru I'm
gonna grow my beard grow my hair get
like a staff and get a traditional
Indian clothing and I'm gonna go to
meditation retreats and yoga retreats
and I'm gonna try to build following and
it was like ridiculous teachings of like
having his followers like new yoga poses
and like things right any item chant
things like mantras and stuff or like
greeting exercises with a snorkel and
like all these kinds of
ridiculous kind of things and then but
then like he gets a core following and
then it starts to feel bad because these
people like really need help and they
also have real problems in the day they
actually feel helped by him even though
he's faking like he's even saying like
oh I am think I am NOT a guru if you
pretend to be a guru you become a guru
like he's telling that to his followers
and then and all these people like them
reframe it into that head is something
different of course yeah and then but
then at the end the question is they
refuse himself and then some people get
really angry and and are don't talk to
him anymore and all the people like its
messages they're like oh it wasn't me I
wasn't the Guru it was your like it was
your own I made you believe in yourself
you did all these like the progress that
you made or the things that got better
into your life you did into your self so
and then became about like some personal
development message about our of self
belief but then the question is like
could I have done it by themselves or
did they need something else to believe
in and also that which we were talking
about is like what Specter the camera
play a role this like the documentary
camera that was there created leverage
for his followers to execute on their
problems you know like if did like one
of them wanted to lose weight that she
knew that in three months or like a
couple or two months they were gonna be
back to shoot more of the documentary
and she knew the camera was gonna be
there suddenly there was more leverage
and accountability to actually lose
weight sure then we're kind of like the
thing okay this is not a defense by the
way of like any lock or anything it's
just more like an exercise thing I mean
you could even put brawler through the
function of religion yeah I don't know
we don't really have time to get into
yeah yeah it's an interesting document
it's an interesting documentary I don't
really know how I feel about it I think
it's pretty I like I acting it's pretty
questionable what he
but you think it's you think he was
being like very immoral that's becoming
fake I think lying to people is immoral
yeah yeah I think I think telling people
especially this is something that I've
thought about recently is like anything
related to health like people tend to
say like well you know adidas or Nike
they sell themselves as something
they're not they basically imply that
they're gonna make you a good athlete or
whatever like how is that different from
figures and I think specifically with
health and wellness I think a different
standard of marketing should be applied
and a stricter standard so like it'd be
it'd be sync anyone has a problem with
like I you know or I think everyone has
a problem with you know some herbal
supplement company saying that they're
gonna cure your cancer and why because
it's there's an inflexible demand people
have to have that and people like people
will spend money they don't have to try
to cure their cans or whatever the same
thing with health and money and
financial like if I think you cannot lie
about the fact that oh I'm gonna make
you a million dollars in the same way
that I think it's like less of a problem
for some just some stupid like pillow or
something to say how great this sleep
their sleep is gonna be or whatever like
I think that's like less of a problem
then somebody being like yeah I'm gonna
make you a millionaire and you can quit
your job and don't go to college and go
go whatever and so I think kumari sort
of falls in the line of like sort of an
inflexible demand of like people are
feeling like spiritually bankrupt and so
he's like oh yeah I can just solve it
you know come to me your yogi who's like
who's like like I just think he is his
goal was to expose exactly what you're
talking about
right but his his thing was like let me
go undercover and just do it for a while
and then eventually kind of pull the
reveal right but he's still doing that
to people for a while yeah so I mean no
okay so that's that's why it was a
documentary class in the morality right
right right right right right oh dude I
actually I saw a way worse documentary
like a horrible documentary where the
documentary filmmaker got like like
people that were homeless and and
mentally like not 100% and put him on
the stage for people office and like he
called he called the documentary call it
the colors forgive me and it was just
like dude people do your hair like
you're terrible yeah yeah yeah I mean I
mean I could not like Borat of course
hugely successful documentary or like
movie they also kind of like um feels
like people's biases and racism and
stuff but then there were there were the
worst a lot of discussion about the
nba's or the not like the disclaimer
contract study I people sign we're like
not honest or whatever the disclaimer
contracts were not exactly honest or in
the documentary and portrayed in a very
bad light we're told something different
about how they were going to be in the
documentary yeah yeah yeah very very
negative effects yeah on their on their
lives so yeah I say another thing like
with documentary because it's always you
know it's like a representation of
reality but it's very much not
documentaries is a creative few points
on reality that is fair easily
influenceable a made here so
yeah but I mean of course like this
stuff that I'm interested but yeah I
think I think it was about it that's me
yeah well it if any final remarks I know
final remarks is go do YouTube yourself
now I'm just kidding join Lars no no no
I appreciate I appreciate your
perspective I definitely realize like I
I know I'm super opinionated and so I
always wet the goal here is never to
like push my viewpoint is the only
viewpoint in fact it's to hopefully get
other viewpoints in to challenge me but
to also challenge you know the concept
of like is coaching really coaching
these days I don't think it is I think
what you're doing is very different from
what most people are doing so I'm glad
we had this kind of discussion and then
have some of these things out and if
anything if anyone is still watching
this video thank you for staying to the
end your check out story if you go if
you go to storytellers from this video
say you're from coffee Zillah to prove
lars wrong prove him wrong okay
subscribe he makes great content
storytellers is and actually one of my
favorite episodes is how to steal like
an artist so go check that out I highly
recommend it even though I do believe
you should also try to be original which
is sort of different but anyways that's
it thanks for coming on the show
[Music]
[Music]
Sakura
[Music]